dans un pays en proie à un tel conflit
obtenir des informations est toujours
compliqué un exercice qui peut s'avérer
particulièrement délicat tant les
billets sont nombreux ainsi le récit des
gouvernements occidentaux et souvent
repris tel quel dans les médias au
mépris parfois de la réalité puisant
leurs informations dans des sources
biaisé comme l'observatoire syrien des
droits de l'homme cités régulièrement
par des agences de presse comme la fp
pour donner des bilans chiffrés sur le
nombre de victimes dans le conflit par
exemple or cette source est plus que
contestable
l'osd achète en effet piloté par une
seule personne basée au royaume-uni et
s'appuyant sur un réseau de sources
locales
pour le moins partisane c'est déjà ce
qu'expose est la journaliste canadienne
eva bartlett en 2016 le sdf n'est pas
crédible
les militants son nom ne sont pas
crédibles une fois ou deux peut-être
mais pas toujours
donc vos sources sur le terrain vous
n'en avez pas en ce qui concerne votre
jean dard pas le vôtre mais celui de
certaines entreprises de médias c'est
l'agenda du changement de régime comment
le new york times que je lisais ce matin
ou democracy now que je lisais l'autre
jour peuvent continuer à assurer qu'il
s'agit d'une guerre civile en syrie
comment peuvent-ils assuré jusqu'à
aujourd'hui que les manifestations
étaient non armés et non violente
jusqu'en 2012
ce n'est absolument pas vrai
dans le même registre il ya les casques
blancs présenté comme une organisation
humanitaire et donc comme une source
fiable par les médias occidentaux
le groupe est en réalité bien plus
controversés ayant reçu des financements
américains les casques blancs sont
décriés pour leur lien direct ou
indirect avec des organisations
terroristes
en syrie un positionnement douteux qui
n'a pourtant jamais remis en question la
légitimité qui leur est accordée dans
les médias et qui pourtant s'explique
comment une organisation humanitaire
pourrait elle opérée au sein de zones
parfois entièrement aux mains des
djihadistes s'en entretenir un minimum
de contact avec eux c'est pourtant
notamment en s'appuyant sur leurs
témoignages que les médias occidentaux
ont repris en boucle les allégations
d'attaqués chimiques et surtout les ont
attribué un peu à la hâte au
gouvernement
si rien malgré les démentis de témoins
locaux de journalistes sur place et les
doutes apparus dans les enquêtes de
l'organisation internationale pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques
ces accusations ont conduit à des
frappes aériennes menées par les
etats-unis le royaume-uni et la france
les médias américains et occidentaux
devraient se rendre compte de leur
responsabilité dans cet incident il y a
quinze ans en 2003 au moment de la
deuxième guerre en irak
la maison blanche a eu recours à un tube
à essai et à son secrétaire d'état colin
powell
aujourd'hui washington utilise les
médias à la place d'un tube à essai à
défaut de pouvoir s'appuyer sur des
sources fiables la plupart des médias
ont donc décidé de coller à la ligne
occidentale
ainsi les islamistes sont présentés en
rebelles et leurs liens avec des groupes
djihadistes aux agissements insoutenable
n'apparaissent pas dans les dépêches
une omission qui s'inscrit étonnamment
dans le storytelling de washington
malgré ce parti pris des médias
occidentaux se mue en arbitre ainsi en
2018 le quotidien libération consacrait
un article au traitement de la guerre en
syrie par des médias tels que nous rt
france derrière les promesses de
révélations et les accusation d'intox se
cachait en réalité une enquête creuser
particulièrement biaisé cerise sur le
gâteau son auteur s'avérait avoir des
liens avec l'opposition syrienne en
remettant en cause la version officielle
avancée par les alliés de l'otan notre
média donc été la cible d attaques
disproportionnées
c'est oublier les précédents lors de la
guerre en yougoslavie ou en irak de
guerre ou les affirmations occidentales
se sont avérées erronées en syrie le
temps fera peut-être aussi son oeuvre
pour soulever les contre-vérités
disséminés pendant les dix années du
conflit